we have some very exciting guests our
glamour is introducing a new generation
of supermodels and it's September cover
story we love this they are called the
new supers the powerful and ambitious
models are from several continents and
they are all size 12 and above a series
of online articles and glamour poses
important questions such as whether the
term plus-size should still be used and
what customers we know where kayla
stands on that no and why customers are
forced to pay a so-called fat tax for
larger sizes beautiful model to my right
Santa bustier is one of those new supers
featured on the cover she has appeared
in campaigns for the beauty brand
Sephora i don't know if you've heard of
it and on the pages of Vogue could not
too shabby she's here with Samantha
berry the editor-in-chief of glamour
Samantha said aboot good morning welcome
to the table this is very excited what
was the genesis of this how did this
idea even come about well September's a
huge fashion moment right in the
industry so your september cover really
has to represent what you stand for in
fashion and my team really came and said
we stand for size inclusiveness
diversity inclusion representation and
this was five months in the planning and
we really wanted to get the right five
new supers to introduce to learn a
walking shot Sam right it's been abou
and Solange and Yvonne Alessandra and
Ezra and it really represents yes
absolutely they're all over size 12
there's sizes 12 to 16 but they
represent so much more about than that
and it's really about people seeing
themselves in a women's title like
glamour and really that discussion
around plus-size right our bigger sizing
is really important to us 68% of women
in America or over a size 14 but they
are only seen in 2% of media like that
is a huge difference yes most of the
women watching here this morning or over
size 14 and they're only seeing
themselves represented in 2% of media it
is crazy I think it's really about it
there's a lot of there's a lot people
like me editors need to make the
decision people that are making programs
content creators they need to make a
decision to normalize and put different
types of people on the covers and the
pages in the storylines on TV that's
really important Center boo
walk in a room and everybody notices
what were you told though when it kind
of went it came to your modeling career
it was just a lot of too much of
something or too little it's like it was
a lot of too tall because I'm 6 foot 2
it was too dark obviously and recently
too skinny because of the language we
have surrounding the curve industry
where you have to be a certain size you
have to fit a certain look so because we
have this binary it's people are
obsessed with putting you on one side of
it or the other so it was just about
breaking those labels and just doing it
for myself saying like I don't have to
look like anyone no one has to look up
to me I just I have to do the job and I
don't I'm not too much of anything I'm
just no but I like what Christian
Siriano said about you you're calm cool
collected powerful confident without
trying too hard that there's a casual
elegance about you what is it that you
want people to know what is the message
you want to send about yourself and
about other models that look like you
for me it's just about let's just
normalize it I think on the other side
of ostracizing women of color or darker
color girls or even curve girls as the
de romanticizing and the exotic sizing
it's just like we have to be spectacular
we don't just get to exist and I just
want to not be a shock when people walk
past me in a campaign or if they walk
past me in the street I want visibility
for all of us it should be normal it
shouldn't be that I'm a token person in
the room or there could only be one but
they can only be one right like it's
okay I would like to see two dark curve
girls or two curve girls and a campaign
at once there seems to be this idea that
one at a time well we need this contrast
so we're just gonna do one at a time and
I just I just want us to be considered
as part of the part of the game so when
you were growing up before magazines
like this existed before issues focused
in this way what were you seeing and
were you seeing yourself and if not
which I'm guessing how how did that
affect you I mean I grew up in Senegal
so there was no lack of beautiful dark
women around me I was surrounded by them
but when I moved to America obviously it
was it was kind of a curve for me for
one we were worn on TV yeah we were
barely in magazines were barely in
commercials anything like that so it
wasn't like I was growing I'm thinking I
want to be XY and Z or I want to look
like XY and Z because we didn't have
that space so now now that we're getting
there it would be nice to not just be
considered this great thing just because
I'm visible I think there's so much more
Sam you were telling me in the green
room that you see this as a call to
action but haven't we heard this call to
action before this exact mass I've heard
it a lot of times but we're still not
there yet right we do a clamor we count
the number of curve girls that are on
the catwalk every Fashion Week and it
actually had a high about two years ago
and it's decreased a little bit it
should be the normal right I think I'm
gonna keep we're gonna keep calling that
action because we're not there yet we're
not they're not represented in a massive
way and it is a multi-billion dollar
industry for there's so many women that
want to buy great fashionable clothes
they want to be in high editorial pieces
and we're not there yet well you're
getting a great reaction or a really
great reaction so hopefully this is a
call to action that people pay attention
to go you Sam yeah it changes one issue
at a time and this is one issue nice to
see you Sam and Sonya thank you very
much for being here appreciate it